what's happening
not much not much i love your plants
thanks
uh let's start with rel what originally
attracted you to this style of
hidden camera prank driven comedy what
was exciting the most challenging about
it for you
well there's a lot of challenges first
of all but what attracted me to the
project is eric andre i'm a big fan of
eric andre's show
just eric in general and this thing
about like eric's world is this right so
it's like
you know i think you're going to his
birthday party he's like maybe fun to do
a prank movie with eric that might be
cool one day
you know the first day i was like uh
damn this i quit
i almost died
but it's really is it's eric andre is so
funny
and just to be a part of this was really
fun and
you know it actually made me respect
eric even more just even that's the way
his writing style is and just to see
somebody who's known for just doing
pranks
to make a narrative prank movie like we
still had a great storyline in the movie
which is really cool and it's like it's
hard in it
but it's it is one of the craziest
experiences of my life i don't think
it's no movie i can do for the rest of
my career that would compare
to bad trip what was the thing on the
first day that made you go
oh i'm going to die oh well you know the
barber shop
when we walked in there we walked in the
wrong barbershop first of all so the
security wasn't in there none of that i
don't know what that brother was going
through before we came in there i don't
know if he had a conversation with him
like yeah let somebody walk in with a
penis is attached i'm gonna kill him you
know i don't know what
because he was so enraged like
everyone asked for help excuse me help
us
oh man what and he just lost it and he
looked like he was looking for a gun
all you could sound like this little
blade or whatever chased us out the
barbershop full speed we break out the
trap i fall on the ground under the car
scraped my elbow and knee
and i remember just you know once they
told to do the thing he was like
oh man that's crazy now almost killed
y'all man
wow this is a movie oh man okay and i
remember just leaving
i didn't they didn't rap me or nothing i
just started walking to the hotel
stealing and stuff and only taking stuff
off yeah yeah this is like walking
around this fake fetus out my jeans
i didn't care what people said people
honking their horn i didn't give a damn
i was like i am done
i called my team and i called my kids
and then i called tiffany
and i didn't even know this part of the
story that when i called tiffany she
called him
yeah so like because i almost got real
killed with a chinese finger trap
prank ralph called tiffany and he's like
i can't do this movie eric's going to
get me killed this is like dangerous
tiffany hung up called me a few minutes
later and she goes yo you almost got
real killed i was like yeah
and then she goes i want to be in your
movie i live for that [ __ ]
i was like what so uh that's how we got
by almost killing rel we enticed
tiffany to be in the movie i mean thank
you for your sacrifice bro
yeah but that's tiffany's crazy man like
she's
saying i remember like i'm like venting
too like dad chip i don't man this is
[ __ ] everyone's got a kid
what that point and she was acting like
that's what makes even great she was
like what i'm gonna call eric and
tell him about herself and she's like
don't put me in a movie man
it's like dammit
uh so this is a one of the wilder movies
i've ever seen there are
threats of violence but eric at least
compared to your show
it does have a very kind of sweet and
wholesome core
to it and i'm curious what was uh what
was it
what were some of the intentions in
having that kind of tone even with some
of the pranks where we see you like
helping someone
in the cold open right well the air
gondry show
does not operate like anything else and
the eric entry show doesn't operate like
the movie the movie the medium of a
movie
you have to have real grounded
characters that are sympathetic
because you're bringing the audience
across 90 minutes of footage
versus the eric andre show which is 11
minutes and i can be as criminally
insane
and psychotic as possible i don't have
to be relatable
or sympathetic there's no narrative
there's no storytelling
this was a different beast so you had to
make my character rel character like
we had to be sympathetic we had to have
a real life story that people could
relate to
but also everything has to be told via
pranks so a lot of the pranks were we
call them help me help me pranks pranks
where
where i'm like rel and i are relying on
the
uh we're in peril and we're relying on
the people we're pranking to help us
um but tiffany got to be more like eric
andre show style prank where she could
just be completely psychotic because
she's the bad guy
so she just gets to break glass and like
rip cop
car doors off and and um and hang me off
a roof
so that was the kind of like technology
that we had to change from the ericander
show to
this but it's still like high stakes
balls to the wall pranks
um that we that we love yeah
and for both of you uh what was it like
having kind of like the godfather of
prank movies jeff tremaine from jackass
what do you feel like he brought to it
and what was it like having that voice
on set
he was the master i mean he he's like
the master splinter like
we came in me and my team my director
kitau my writing partner dan curry we
would come in and like pitch all these
like kind of like
crazy ideas and he was like that that's
great those are funny pranks but it
doesn't make a movie it doesn't make a
movie and he really like
buckled down on like there has to be
storytelling you have to have a story
told even though it's pranks
you have to have a story story first the
characters have to be relatable
and sympathetic and likable all the
rules of a movie still apply even though
it's pranks
so we were really kind of resistant to
that at first and then we realized like
no the pranks that are on story are the
most
rewarding pranks to watch like when rel
and i have a scene where there's a big
falling out between our characters
i destroy the car we have this big like
kind of breakup scene
and it's one of the most like uh
entertaining scenes in the movie because
we have these real people that didn't
even know they were on camera
helping us out and trying to like mend
our friendship and like
and then like me and rel have a makeup
scene on a bus that's like when harry
met sally
and these people are like really
emotionally invested i mean she started
tearing up
you saw a girl or no girl started
tearing up it's really she's like oh my
god
it's like us to stay like him stop at
the bus
i like that that was our jerry maguire
moment yeah totally
totally so jeff brought that like 20
extra year experience to the table and
all the trials and tribulations that he
went through on
three jackass movies and bad grandpa he
was able to come and bring to us and be
like i'm telling you from experience
like
this is what to do and what not to do in
this situation so
yeah he's the master we learn that's why
like season five that your andre show is
like
kind of the best season yet because we
use all his little tricks and tools and
wisdom to uh make like the best pranks
possible so
yeah that's awesome thanks so much for
your time guys great talking to you
thank you